den menschen sehen nicht nur den fall
katharina rätsel ist das wichtig
auch wenn es viele fälle sind zu viele
die intensiv medizinerin am wald
klinikum in gera beschreibt die
situation hier als besorgniserregend
sind bisher gut durch die letzten drei
wellen gekommen und dass die vier
tabelle so
schwierig und schlimm für uns wird wenn
man es erzielt wenn es sich so weiterhin
es wirklich mache deutlich so wie
seit wochen kommen täglich fälle dazu
täglich schicksale für die mitarbeiter
eine belastende situation schon wieder
schwere erkrankungen sind sie gewohnt
auf intensiv aber die pandemie die toten
die dauer das übersteige das mass
wir sind ausgebrannt muss man einfach
sagen dass intensiv personal ist
ausgebrannt hatte auch das gesamte
krankenhauspersonal es am ende aus
gedrängt weil es natürlich immer
erschwerte arbeitsbedingungen sind durch
die
circa 30 der patienten hier haben im
durchbrüche meist ältere die das virus
vor dem boostern erwischt hat weil der
impfschutz langsam nachlässt die
mehrheit aber umkämpft es darf ins
medizinische nicht mit einfließen war
aber moralisch ist das sehr sehr schwer
für uns nur weil wir eine neue belastung
aber wir wissen wir hätten ja was tun
können sie die patienten selber hätten
ja was können sie tun trotzdem alles für
jeden corona fall und in jedem
krankenhaus auch im eine stunde
entfernten saalfeld ländliche regionen
mit vielen im skeptikern trifft auf die
delta variante die folge volle station
sagt auch pfleger ronny bayern wie er
seien viele am limit auch mit dem
verständnis das ist halt gerade diese
sehr verbreitet und na ja auch im
privaten hat man damit zu tun dass eben
leute eben da sehr skeptisch sind und
das macht einen schon auch mal sauer
dass man aufgrund dieser menschen
teilweise wieder in die situation kommen
denn der auch schon mal und um
eigentlich dachten dass man darüber
hinaus sind
für ihn heißt dass
arbeitsgeschwindigkeit eiltempo sein
pensum steigt stetig weil viele kollegen
einfach nicht mehr können krank
ausgelaugt raus aus dem beruf nach fast
zwei jahren pandemie
der kamera stand hat sich aufgrund der
hohen arbeitsbelastung leben auch erhöht
wir haben auch kolleginnen und kollegen
die da nicht wiederkommen gründen nach
ihrer eigenen erkrankung und die ganze
situation ist auch dadurch verschärft
dass durch den druck eben auch viele
kollegen auch wirklich das handtuch
geschmissen haben ronny bayers
eigentliche station geschlossen die
hälfte der mitarbeiter umdisponiert auf
die pandemie station wird keiner gedacht
dass es noch mal weihnachten wirklich
mal
schutzkittel anziehen ausziehen bei
jedem handgriff am patienten der aufwand
auf den corona stationen ist groß das
personal das sie hier zusätzlich
brauchen wird anderswo abgezogen
chefarzt robert kästner beobachtet die
steigenden instanzen mit sorgen also
werden chirurgische abteilungen
schließen müssen insbesondere
wir haben einzelne internistische
fachbereiche nicht mehr
bedienen können und wir sehen natürlich
jetzt auch für die nächsten wochen und
monate das sehr kritisch das weitere
bereiche der korona versorgung zum opfer
fallen auch helge kerl wartet auf seine
op bei ihm kam jetzt noch corona dazu
trotz impfung
vorausgeht und co
er wird im krankenhaus warten müssen
viele andere zu hause wegen corona und
personalschwund zehn prozent der
mitarbeiter sind weg
denn auch über den sommer ohne pandemie
war hier schon hochbetrieb versuchten
sie die verschobenen op vom letzten
winter auf zu arbeiten wo man muss der
patient seine hüfte bekommen oder dabei
ein muss operiert werden und in der zeit
hat man das eben versucht aufzuholen und
dadurch war eben auch keine entspannung
möglich dass man sagt wir können jetzt
mal nach der ganzen situation mal
runterfahren was viele mitarbeiter
stattdessen heruntergefahren haben sind
die arbeitsstunden auf ihrer station
sagt intensiv medizinerin rauxel in gera
arbeiten die meisten nur noch teilzeit
technik ohne personal wenn man jetzt
gute station nimmt haben wir 36
intensivbetten oder intensiv plätze
können davon ging auf dem wie das
personal ist zwischen 24 bis 28
betreiben corona sagt sie verstärkt
massiv das problem im system es muss
sich lohnen und eine schicht system zu
arbeiten das muss sich lohnen kein
weihnachten und silvester zu haben
sondern da er auf arbeit zu sein das
muss ich besser mit der hoffnung dass
dann auch mehr kollegen bei uns arbeiten
und damit natürlich auch die belastung
deutlich sich oft mehr
für die nächsten wochen rechnen sie
damit dass sich die zahl der
intensivpatienten weiter erhöht und
hoffen dass sie es schaffen